what is going on everybody welcome to
another robotics and python and
raspberry pi tutorial video this video
in the subsequent few is going to be
covering the addition of this distance
sensor this is the hc sro4
so by now uh my raspberry pi car is
using that anchor for portable power to
the pi and we've got that edimax wi-fi
dongle so our car is now remote
controllable via wi-fi and could
actually be controlled via the internet
in say a browser or via some sort of
phone app
but now we want to add a distance sensor
to it so we can begin to make the
transition to an autonomous robot so for
me i'm more interested in the software
aspect than the hardware aspect and i'm
more interested in having
a robot be autonomous rather than remote
controllable luckily along the path to
autonomy we can also just add in remote
control anyways so we have already done
that but my goal is more
for more autonomy so for that we want to
start adding sensors one of the easiest
sensors is this hc sro4 and so we're
going to be using that so this is a
distance sensor what it is is an
ultrasonic sensor that uses sonar to
determine the distance of objects from
it much like bats do so what it does is
it's going to transmit some sound and
that's sound is going to travel to an
object so basically what this is going
to do is say it shoots sound out of here
it's going to travel to this object
bounce back and be received okay
and from here using the known constant
of the speed of sound
the amount of time it takes to occur
we can use these together and we can
accurately measure how far away an
object is
so some of you guys might be thinking
what about what about
angles so right here if this was to
shoot to this breadboard and back that's
a straight shot but what if it was like
this well the sound might bounce here
and it might actually miss the sensor so
because of this we have to kind of take
this into consideration so from a bunch
of tests
this sensor performs best at less than a
22 degree angle and anything over a 30
degree angle should really just be
distrusted so for this reason we can
bring more sensors on board and use the
lowest distance measurement uh as
our distance okay so we can bring more
sensors on board and also we can
pre-program that that specific sensor's
spot right that specific sensor's
placement on the car or whatever we have
and we use the lowest one to determine
which sensor is the most accurate okay
and so um
so we can do that because
if if the degree is higher than 30
either what's going to happen is either
it it just doesn't get a signal back or
when it finally does come back it's a
massive number like 500 or like let's
say 500 centimeters because we're gonna
use centimeters so say an object was 45
degrees away what's going to happen is
say it was like this it's going to
bounce off here come to me bounce back
and then bounce to the receiver so for
this reason it's unlikely that you'll
get an angle like with an angle it's not
it's unlikely that you'll get a false
positive that an object is too close but
you might certainly get false negatives
and actually an object is much closer
than we thought so enough on that let's
go ahead and break down this specific
sensor so as you can see the hc sro4 has
basically four connections to it you've
got vcc trig which is trigger echo and
gnd for ground vcc is basically the
power and this is a 5 volt sensor so
you're going to need to send 5 volts to
this trigger is going to be triggered by
an output a gpio output and that's going
to trigger the release of an ultrasonic
wave
then echo echo is basically receiving so
that's going to be a gpio input so
trigger
you can basically what's going to happen
is you're going to trigger it mark the
time at trigger and then once you
receive a signal back at echo you mark
the time and then ground just goes to
ground now keep in mind this is again
five volts so the only main the only
issue that we're going to have here is
that the hcs r04 is 5 volts the pi is
3.3 and so if this sends back a high
signal back to the gpio input pin on the
raspberry pi we might have some problems
because uh that's going to be too much
for the pi and you could damage your pi
so obviously we don't want to do that so
the items that we're going to need are
the following we're going to need
two
male to female
jumper wires and they're going to you're
going to want them to be of decent
length because it's going to wire from
our pi to the breadboard
the breadboard is basically i'm going to
use the breadboard you don't have to but
i'm going to use the breadboard to stick
the sensor into because the breadboard
will hold up our sensor quite nicely so
the breadboard will just go right on top
of our car
luckily for me my breadboard actually
screws in perfectly to the board these
two screws fit perfectly this breadboard
didn't come with the kit i just got
extremely lucky
otherwise just use like double-sided
tape put double-sided tape on here and
stick it on your pie or you could glue
it if you wanted but do something like
that
so you're going to need a breadboard
obviously the hc sro4
two
male to female jumper wires and then two
male to male jumper wires i ended up
having to stick two together just
because my only male to male jumper wire
was really short
so i connected it to a female to male
jumper wire and just electrical taped it
up
and then i have another red one so two
male to male two male to female one
breadboard one hcs ro4 and finally
you're going to need a
um
one kiloohm resistor and that one
kiloohm resistor is what we're going to
add to the gpio input right so we're
going to add that to the echo so
before we send it back to the pi it goes
through the resistor and that will be
enough
so we don't overload our pi
so enough on that how are we going to
wire this so obviously uh the first
thing we have is this ground so you're
going to want to put the ground in and
let me go ahead and actually sense or
center my sensor as best as possible so
there and if you don't know much about
breadboards the we're not going to use
any of these sides but these the way a
breadboard works is it's like this
usually you can see it's numbered or
lettered on the sides
and basically it works horizontally so
anything you connect like this like
we're connecting you know perpendicular
but anything here like this whole row is
all connected you can't see it because
we've got it back on here but they're
all connected so basically it's it's an
easy way to make a circuit without
soldering or soldering
so anything we put in line here will be
a part of this but it won't interfere
with these but of course you could make
the connection if you wanted
we're just going to choose not to so
anyway
if we look back at our front
vcc is over here so this is where the
power is so for me i try to denote power
with red
then we have
trig is the next thing and followed by
echo so trig will make it orange
so we'll plug that one and actually uh
i'm going to plug them in
at the very end here just so they're all
kind of uniform with each other just in
case you wanted to throw something else
into that line so red and then we'll
plug the orange for trigger you can use
any colors you want
maybe maybe i'll plug it in i can't get
it to go in
there we go
right so initially i had wired this up
wrong and i decided i better re-upload
it since
it's fairly it's a fairly big deal if
you wire it up wrong and break your pie
i've probably put in at least a few
hours with it wired up wrong and didn't
have any problems but it is possible to
to um to break your pie this way or the
way i had done it anyways so i figured i
better go over it and special thanks to
the sticky ouk and andrew baggett for
pointing it out
um pretty stupid mistake
anyway
so what i had done
was basically the way the breadboard
works again is you have these these
holes right and they're all connected
horizontally
and underneath them the way that they
work is there's just a metal track and
so when you plug into the hole it
connects everything but what will happen
is what i had done is i connected this
yellow pin on the same side so on the
same track
and use the resistor thinking that's
going to you know resist the current or
whatever and that would solve our
problem but what was going to happen or
what did happen and luckily i didn't get
any trouble for myself was
it would the current is going to take
the path of least resistance which would
just be the track underneath so the
resistor was really doing nothing
besides directing the current away from
it basically so that was worthless so
instead what you have to do is we can
leave all the other connections like
we've got
but we use the resistor to bridge the
gap here because this gap
the tracks don't follow under it so we
can use the resistor to bridge the gap
and then plug our yellow input
jumper wire into this track over here
using the resistor so the only path
possible is now through the resistor
but still a pretty important
thing that you have to take into
consideration and not plug things in if
you're going to use a resistor in the
same track
so anyways that's that and we'll
continue on with the rest of the video
all right so here's the car uh go ahead
and just you know delicately take your
pie out and your h-bridge out
so
take the pi like so
and the h bridge like so i guess i have
to kind of move the battery pack a
little bit to get this all to come out
for us
and let's move it over
there
okay
gotta get the input pins on
so once we've got that out the next
thing we want to do is we want to begin
plugging in the gpio input pins
to our pi and then also we want to plug
in what we need to our h bridge the h
bridge plugs we're going to plug into
that 5 volt and then we're also going to
plug in to the ground on the h
bridge um so yeah so them so now that
we've got those on here let me figure
out how i'm going to stick my i guess
i'll put the breadboard here you've
already seen the breadboard so you'll
just see the wires coming off the screen
i suppose
and
maybe i can move it up a little bit
there
there we go okay so first we want to
plug in let's go ahead and plug in the
input and output pins on our raspberry
pi
okay so let's begin so first we're going
to plug in the orange wire and the
orange wire is corresponding to our
trigger
and we're going to plug that into gpio
pin
18 or pin 12 on the pi and that is
basically
two pin gap so it's the third pin down
from our ground on our pi
so
right
here and i'll hold it up like this so
you've got a gap of two pins and then we
plug in our orange and that's for the
trigger so that's going to be an output
pin
and then the next one we have is our
yellow pin and that's our input pin and
that's going to be for echo and that one
gets plugged in basically
with a gap below gpio pin 18 then you've
got gpio 23
so that one goes right here
if i can get it on there
there we go
okay
so it should look like
um like this see if i can get it to
focus
there so we have here our five volt
with one gap then you've got ground then
you've got two pins and you've got your
orange and this is for
the trigger
one more pin then you've got the yellow
for echo
so those are in now
and now we have to connect all of this
to the h bridge because we're going to
take our power from the h bridge because
we've already got
our gpio pin is already being exhausted
so we might as well just use the same
thing it's going to
so
for the power here so my red cord we're
going to plug this right into the vcc on
our age bridge so for me
that was we used a green wire for that
so
let's see maybe i can shift this stuff
make it easier to see
okay so that would be
uh if you had your your thing facing me
that's going to be right here
right next to ground and then after that
we're going to plug our ground into this
one so let's go ahead and do that i'm
just going to loosen this one up a
little bit
and we'll take our
vcc which is 5 volt we're plugging that
into the 5 volt slot basically we're
sharing the slot with
the 5 volt power that we're grabbing
from the pi anyways
screw that on
screw it fairly firmly you don't want to
kill it give give both of a decent tug
make sure they're in there good mine are
so now we're ready to plug in the ground
and that will be the black wire here
so again just kind of unscrew your
ground a little bit that's the middle
one
and then fit your
your other ground in there
there we go
okay once you've got that one in there
give them both a nice uh tug make sure
they're both in there what sometimes
when you're sticking two in there um
one might be snug but the other one
might not be so
just make sure that they're in there
good so now we've got everything hooked
up and i'm going to kind of put
everything back into
my car no real reason to leave
everything strewn out like this and just
for anybody who is curious the way that
i've been doing it is i take the battery
pack and i slide that all the way to the
back because that will um it fits nicely
underneath these like these won't hit
your batteries
so i slide the battery pack all the way
into the back
sometimes apparently i can't today there
we go
okay so that's all the way in the back
and then i try my best to just kind of
stuff both of these in here
uh this one's it's just a little bit
harder to do the pie in the h bridge but
usually i can make it work
the only problem i've been having so far
is with the pie
uh sometimes i lose the signal from the
edamax well which makes sense because
we're encasing this into a metal box
basically so you could put your pie on
top i like it when it's nice and clean
so i just want to put it on there
in the inside and my goal is really
autonomy not necessarily remote control
so it just kind of works out but you can
put the pie on top i mean there's
nothing horribly wrong with that
and we will be putting the breadboard on
top at least so anyway
i'm going to pack these in here real
quick and then i'll
resume once i get everything in the car
all right so once you've got
everything put back together
like i said my breadboard just so
happened to luckily
fit two screw holes here so that worked
out
so we were able to get that on there got
everything wired up i'm just threading
the wires through
the back here
and then also the power to the anchor is
here
and that's pretty much it as far as
wiring it up goes uh just make sure you
haven't forgot your one kill ohm
resistor
for the gpio input pin so we don't break
our pi
and other than that we are ready to
begin to code this so we're going to
continue on in the next video with
setting up the pins and taking some test
measurements making sure our sensor
works and then from there we'll actually
start building this into the autonomy of
the raspberry pi cars so that's what you
guys have to look forward to if you have
any questions or comments feel free to
leave them below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time